I want to start with uh that doesn't
happen in a lot of collider screenings
that is a very unique thing
um how did you guys like the little coda
Bradford Healthcare she should have
stabbed him
she should have cut his neck
outside sorry we were arguing in the
hallway about and then we made it all
like if you did halfway and did he
always said come that happened does he
stop her or is he gonna no man have her
just six
I like seeing you guys uh argue over
things it's actually fantastic before we
get started I want to give a huge thank
you to IMAX for being an amazing partner
and for
th
a huge thank you and to everyone
standing over there for making this
happen
um obviously I want to start with uh
just a moment to just reflect on Lance
and his contributions to the films and
uh you know just if you wouldn't mind
giving it up for Lance
foreign
[Applause]
a great man good friend good artist he's
one of the original cast members at
started the John Wick franchise I think
he was one of the first people we ever
cast actually
back on the first stone week so
um before we go any further I just want
to also say a thank you to the two of
you and I think I speak for everyone in
this room I I know how hard it is to
make movies to make a movie like this is
is really really effing hard and I just
want to thank you for all the work you
guys did to make this thank you
[Applause]
you guys have put on screen some
incredible action set pieces and I am
curious with the four films what do you
think were like the top three in terms
of the difficulty from staging filming
everything that went into it training
what what were the top three Eric day
Triumph well that's pretty hard
a lot of cars a dog it's not men that's
all I got you got dog Triumph was a
little tricky
Halle Berry number three the dogs a lot
of dogs the dogs a lot of crutches yeah
and learning I mean what about I mean
just even like the first one because we
didn't know what the heck we were gonna
no dinner and that probably yeah like
the first like the uh home invasion
like that kind of was like that that was
pretty rough I mean it wasn't rough
rough Club but I mean oh yeah let's go
to the club yeah piano had like a fever
there no but we also I mean you might
have known it was gonna happen but I
certainly didn't know
yeah probably we got that from you we
didn't want to tell you too much
but uh yeah probably the nightclub first
movie was pretty good just because it
was so new yeah we were clueless I mean
and then the you know what about the the
party scene fight in Rome on two I
forgot about the rock concert yeah the
rock concert fight that was pretty
awesome yeah but about three
horses riding horses getting off of
horses but that is number two so horses
the horses in Brooklyn the Brooklyn does
not like horses we're just picking the
somebody has so we're taking all the
time
no question here no we forgot that we
had trains yeah so we had to do a horse
Chase under trains Horses Don't Like
Trains no so every 20 minutes the train
would combine the horses would have to
take off and he was yeah but people
think it's just me riding it's like this
whole rig with a guy who actually
steering a horse looking backwards
that's the horse went crazy I fell off
and like buried into the back yeah it
wasn't very John Wayne I like how it
basically go to every movie you're just
mentioning every set piece and being
like that wasn't Possible Oh that was
impossible we keep trying to get better
but sometimes it doesn't work out
though so Chad told me that the way you
guys come up with uh the next
installment is at the Imperial Hotel in
Tokyo over whiskey that's happened a
couple of times right so for people that
could you sort of pull back the curtain
on that is it literally you guys at the
bar drinking a certain kind of whiskey
and just shooting the
well what happens is the the film gets
released in Japan usually a few months
after the states and so
we we've known what the reaction from
from the American audience is and I
guess the studio Lionsgate has a
perspective on whether they want to make
another one or not and so it's usually
in in Japan where it's either like
oh they said we can do another one and
then we look at each other and go well
what do you want to do I don't know and
then we just make up we usually
come out of Japan with at least one or
two ideas always one one or two ideas
that's the whiskey yeah can I ask what
is the whiskey of choice for each of you
no
um
yamazaki 21 yeah that's probably
something biki 21 is is quite good and
also impossible to get not in Japan
yeah so for this one the idea was we you
know because we have to come up with a
why right what's the why why make it and
after chapter one well just after John
Wick it was like the why well he's on
the run but even before On The Run maybe
let's open up the world and it was like
the marker and all of the friendships
and then chapter four was wine making
and was like okay he has to die
that would seem like the only reason to
make it
you know what I mean like it's
impossible he can't survive the high
table I mean you keep fighting that's
the whiskey talking not yet wait till
Monday
uh which of the four films and and uh
I'm curious for Chad which of the four
films changed the most in the editing
room in ways you didn't expect
ah good question
um I would say probably number three
number three we kind of shifted the
second act around a little bit um funny
enough I think
obviously there's a lot of work
depending on you you try to really find
the Thruway to the story like on number
four as you guys just watch we try to do
a lot of different characters and a lot
of different story lines all converging
on on John's storyline
um number four is most like the script I
think of all the movies
um I think it's the truest to the script
as far as editorial goes number the same
time I think
number two it's end of second act number
three we had to find a little bit with
all the Montage stuff but I think number
three was where we shifted story a
little bit more in editing to really to
really streamline it I think number
three was only we're just under two
hours on that one so I think that was
probably the most streamlined one we had
so this film is 240 plus credits let's
say something like that how long was
your director's cut on this one oh 345
easy
no credits like right on no intermission
I just have to ask when you say the
directors cut 345 you mean like that's
an assembly cut or that's a cut that you
actually thought about showing uh no
that's what we show the studio
yeah that was funny
um yeah but I I think
um I think how not to get the studio on
your side yeah by Chad Stahl scan go to
Chad stalski's Film School
um but I think
um there's probably like 15 minutes just
for enjoyment for me I'd probably put
back in because it just had it had a lot
more Berlin it was more wool building
but I think the view we released is
probably the absolutely the best version
of everything we've tried we tried all
kinds of different stuff just just to
proof check it but I think this is the
best version but there's cool little
scenes that just didn't make it
um with Keanu and Berlin he finds guns
that's why
you know there's this whole Berlin part
and there's a lot more there's a lot
more Club fight there's a lot more Arc
to Triumph a lot more so can I ask and
obviously we're talking about the
theatrical release in IMAX theaters and
yeah you know but is but is there a
chance like the Blu-ray would have
some of these scenes
um I don't know I I think there's some
pretty funny scenes I think that we did
that will probably get released at some
point you know I don't know if it'll be
part of another cut but I don't know
we'll see how we do on on Monday so when
you're doing at this is for both of you
when you're doing an action scene with
uh people fighting generally there's no
extras because you can control the
environment
and in this film you decided to do a
Berlin club scene that involved people
music lights rain Scott Atkins being
amazing and uh just basically making an
impossible scene so who who was like
this is what we're gonna do
yeah
um I mean you were you've met with the
production designer that was like almost
it's like almost a post whiskey idea of
like I want there to be water and a club
scene yeah my dad said so very you know
really my dad's a plumber so I grew up
with all these water fixtures growing up
and he had this waterfall feature in a
house that we worked on when I was like
14. I was like I'm gonna use that in a
movie and uh we just put 40 of them in
instead of just 45
000 gallons a minute like 45
000 gallons of water a minute in that
club yeah
but but I have but I want the extras we
always like this when you do martial
arts choreography you're always trying
to create the maze what's the set piece
you watch Jackie Chan or any of the
great Hong Kong guys do it and there's
always a maze you know they're going
through hallways going through things
there's always an obstacle
um so you've seen us do it with glass
with mirror rooms and then you know the
club we do it with people you know
movable walls which we call like
background extras it takes a lot of time
it takes a lot more coordination but
there's about 20 or 30 of them that are
all professional dancers that were
always surrounding Keanu in the cast and
then we took that idea of movable walls
and we just went no well we did with
people let's do it with cars and that's
how we did it with the Arctic Triumph I
want to ask you Kiana if you don't mind
um filming that Berlin Club sequence
because I've never I could be wrong but
I think this is the first time I've seen
you doing action with that many extras
behind you and around you what is that
actually like as a performer knowing you
have all these people and and resetting
it it takes I don't know 10 20 minutes
or whatever it might be
uh just kind of start working that out
when you start when the camera sets up
so when you start moving with the study
cam operator and you start filling in
all the extras they get familiar with
what's going to happen
um and then if you have to go through
people Chad usually puts in some stunned
people that she can shovel for shove
away and stuff blockers yeah we always
have a couple blockers not just like I
just um I'm just dancing and probably
John Wick hits you in the face
um
so it's like really they get you kind of
get
um know the situation get acclimatized
everyone kind of gets through the
repetition of it and
um yeah yeah a lot of rehearsals I mean
most of the the way we do the martial
art choreography the way our stunt guys
train is mostly like dancers anyways all
based on memory emotion and group dance
or group performance so when we get
together with you know I got my 30s done
guys plus 30 of the dance people they
all kind of work well together and then
we just build the extras out you know in
sections of 50 so you can train them and
then put them in and you realize who's
good who's not who's got the right look
who doesn't you kind of partition them
off to be in different sequences it does
take time but I think the effect is very
cool so can I ask how long does a
sequence like that how long did it take
you to actually film
um in in the club with the upstairs I
think um
I want to say probably nine days total I
think nine to ten days for all of for
the upstairs gambling and the club
sequence and how long before you step on
set are you training for that practicing
for that all the extras are practicing
and how much is all being figured out
right there on set oh um Keanu and the
stunt guys have rehearsed oh yeah so
when they were filming uh hiroyuki and
Donnie Yen scene when they're having
their showdown in the Osaka Continental
in the beginning of the film I was in
another room where we were filming in
Berlin just training and learning
choreography
um because my fight scene was up after
that
um and then for the club stuff yeah so I
was training during the weekends because
there was a lot of there was some dog
hits that aren't in the movie so I was
training dog hits getting hit by the dog
and pulled by the dog
um
yeah so it's like a mix there's like
stuff that's known training for what's
known and then in and then make it up
um I don't know I guess for my
interactions that are in the movie
that's pretty much all
um uh Korea uh set choreographed I
definitely want to talk about you have
an incredible winner uh does everyone in
this room know what a wanter is or
actually let's we should explain what a
wander is for people that don't know but
you have the one are seen where you lift
the camera up and it's going over
everything and you're using the dragon's
breath shotgun that sequences pardon my
language I'm gonna I'm gonna hold back
cursing it is awesome uh it is just
awesome
um can you sort of talk about filming
that that using the one or why you
wanted to do a winner and Keanu can you
talk a little bit about the dragon's
breath shotgun
it's pretty awesome
um I I think we just knew as we were
designing the sequence we wanted to ramp
up like in the third act so it goes from
one set piece to another second
obviously Arctic Triumph the driving to
the apartment building with the dragon's
breath the top Sean and then of course
we want to end with the Buster Keaton
staircase idea so we needed something to
kind of elevate all the gun food that we
had been doing and we just thought well
we trade off so much with the Video Game
World and we we like so many of like
Asian Cinema so you want to do a Top
Shot but it was you know most most
people don't do the top shots because
you just look down at the floor and
there's not a whole lot there it's a
black carpet or something so we started
talking to the production designers and
Dan Laos and the cinematographer about
how do we make this interesting how to
make it fun and then we were doing our
Rabbit Hole dive on all our weaponry and
martial art choreography and we forgot
that we were going to use the dragon's
breath somewhere else in the movie but
like we saw that you know from a top
view it had that beautiful muzzle flash
and guys on Fires I'm like okay well
we'll just paint the picture with other
than practical lighting we'll do it with
stunt guys on fire
um Dan lauster was really excited about
that we can light this out with people
on fire and the dragon's breath and give
it that surreal kind of anime look
so we started developing the four-point
flying system that we flew the camera on
and then we had to build the set that
was at the right height and we needed
the staircase so we saw Keanu come up so
you know it's him and we just kind of
telescope up and just kind of live in
that world for a little bit kind of
video gaming but it also gives it that
different perspective so you can
actually see the Tactical gunfu gun
the Tactical Kung Fu going on so you can
see the bad guys before John Wick did
which makes it kind of fun when you see
all the bullets penetrating so we try to
do a horizontal
Etch A Sketch as we call it
um just with color and Kiana can you
talk a little bit about getting to use
the shotgun yeah shotgun was uh awesome
because of the way that we use rounds
the technology they're all plugged guns
so nothing actually comes out of the
barrel
so I don't get to see all that fire it's
all kind of post fire I get to hear the
sound and get to see the shells eject
um and uh yeah so I get that little
pop-up pop but I don't get to see any I
don't I saw some people on fire
um
and uh and so the way it was stitched
together we basically I had to do all
the choreography someone would count out
loud because the sequence needed to sync
with the camera on its fly system so it
was like one two
and you're like
3 and 11 12 13 14.
and that would be the end of the take
that's I just want you I just want you
to realize how much the stunt training
stays with you afterwards
so I obviously need to talk about the
Paris stuff specifically that staircase
uh for people that don't realize that is
really people going down the stairs that
is not CGI no that's all real stunt
people yeah it's Vincent uh
is
tearful it's
I mean I want to talk about the arcade
Triumph as well but I really want to
just real quick on the staircase where
did that idea come from to do the
staircase of course that's right a chad
now you don't sleep much
um before you explain it though how long
did you actually have to film that
sequence and do all those stunts uh just
the stairs yeah just the stairs I think
we had sacrificure for like seven days
total uh with the scene up top so I
think we're on the stairs we went over a
week
yeah so maybe five six days just on the
staircase yeah it's at least five at
least five yeah I actually don't know
how you film all that in five days
um again we rehearsed very differently
than teams we were we over we rehearse a
lot and we have Keanu that we can move
much quicker when you're not dividing it
up between doubles and wires and safety
and you're doing on the real location
it's as fast as the crew can move you
have a good crew you have a good
rehearsal and you have a cast member
that does 98 of it himself then you can
move fairly quick you just gotta have a
plan you gotta have great people that
can put it together you know and we've
always been great operators yeah we have
great great camera operators like
outstanding operators
uh Keanu can you talk a little bit about
filming that staircase sequence what was
your reaction when you heard what was
coming
and talk a little bit about filming
there because that that sequence is
incredible and I mean the whole theater
was I think I think everyone enjoyed
that one yeah man I love the humor yeah
thank you thank you thank you yeah man I
love the humor of the scene I like that
he's just kind of looking at that thing
it's Sisyphus it's
um Buster Keaton so I thought there was
humor in it uh the physically
challenging but we lucked out with some
pretty good weather it wasn't too cold
it was nice just wet enough yeah yeah
someone was just wet well and then the
wet downs but um but uh you know it's
really fun sequence to do and it was
really cool to actually do it solo have
Vincent do that crazy stair fall and
then the second stair phone and the
third stairfall and then it was cool to
kind of do that part with I love the way
it just dramatically you know um John
Wick and Kane partner up and go back up
and then it's a whole other feeling to
it
um but yeah it was it was physically
intense
um but it was fun uh Arc de Triumph um
that sequence is another one that I I
watched it again tonight I'm like I
don't understand how they filmed this
you know so can you sort of just talk a
little bit about uh filming that and you
standing there where cars are going by
you and and the fact that that's really
happened
yeah don't don't go out of your lane
um we have we have a amazing stun team
that we had to figure out how to do it
safely and still have the speed going by
um what you don't see we put down all
these little cone markers different
colored cone markers so all the stunt
drivers know which lane they're in the
red lane they're in the blue land in the
Green Lane and then we have little spot
markers almost like uh like twister
keanu's got to stay in his footpath to
make sure
um that's it just have really good
people and don't don't step too far left
don't step too far and right yeah and so
they also integrated wire work and then
we had some green foam cars so that
people were taking hits off of like
moved well they had the ramp system
so we had some guys some wires we'd have
two people go off a car one guy would go
on a wire in the background
shot him in the head most uh in the
movie and uh so there's wire work
there's live cars there's stun this
effects oriented cars most of the time
uh sorry um when a guy's getting hit by
a car sometimes being hit it's only
about you know 10 15 miles an hour
that's considered a pretty extreme car
hit mass times let's see anyway see
another
Force
um but when we wanted to get more speed
out of the car say upwards of 18 to 20
miles an hour that's a hard hit for a
stunt guy and the hitting the car is the
hard part but hitting the ground is the
much harder part so we put the guys in
these small wire systems so when we hit
we put a special pad on the windshield
so they don't get hung up stunk guys pad
up they rehearse we hit him with the car
they go up and we slow down their rate
of descent so we can put them down the
ground a little bit easier so they can
survive
the probability of surviving is much
greater than we do we try to make it as
safe as we could and still get a great
impact
uh Donnie Yen is incredible in this I
mean really it's just he's so good and
uh yeah uh talk a little bit about
getting to actually do fight scenes with
him and the fact that because he really
brought his A-game to the this is you
know what I mean yeah all of that
yeah he's exceptional
um yeah uh
yeah what do I say uh the first time
that I have we we the first sequence we
had together with the action was the
first scene that they actually have
together
um and basically we kind of interact and
then we come around I draw and then he
unleashes the cane and all of the
choreography we had went out the window
I was just like I'm too slow he's doing
stuff and I just turned it to Jeremy I
was like that's not gonna work because I
was supposed to like Parry and then
disengage and just and he's like
and I loved it because he was true to
his character and what came out of that
moment I feel feels really alive because
it's like John Wick he gets kicked back
and then John just gets the out of
there
he's like and he kept going at me and it
was just um that was actually real I
think the take you took is take you took
is that's real yeah like a second take I
think yeah it was like we decided
that John Wick's out of there yeah just
out of there and it was cool it was even
good status right candle just turned in
going this and running like check
the Gateway but he's so beautiful I mean
he's just you know his flavor is so
amazing and
um yeah it's high hand we're basically
out of time but just real fast um for
people that don't know you actually
there's a little bit more of John Wick
in uh at some point when ballerina comes
out yeah I got to wear the suit one more
time which was nice it's a film that um
Len wiseman's directing into armises in
and they were kind enough to kind of
collaborate with Chad and I on the
timeline so it takes place between
chapter 3 and chapter four
a few quick things real fast number one
if you enjoyed the movie please use this
thing called social media to maybe say
something doesn't hurt number two these
guys have to get to another q a tonight
so I would ask that everyone stays
seated so they can actually get to the
next q a ladies and gentlemen Chad and
Keanu thanks Steve thank you so much
thanks everyone thank you thanks guys